[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily what
to expect as we await closing arguments
and deliberations in the derrick chauvin
trial did the former minneapolis cop
make the right decision to not testify
in his own defense is this a guy who
would do well in front of a jury and the
defense medical expert now facing his
own lawsuit in the death of a teen in
police custody we speak to a former
baltimore detective on dr david fowler's
decades-long career as the chief medical
examiner in maryland i thought he was
phenomenal plus police body cam and
surveillance videos released in the
fatal shooting of a 13-year-old boy the
chicago mayor reacting to video of the
death of adam toledo they are incredibly
difficult to watch
minneapolis covering the derrick chauvin
trial and with us is co-host terry
austin testimony has wrapped up in the
trial of the former cop charged in the
death of george floyd brian buckmeyer is
here to explain what to expect from
closing arguments and deliberations
brian
jesse the judge sent the jury home
thursday afternoon they're expected to
be sequestered in a hotel once
deliberation begins
closing arguments are scheduled for
monday morning the prosecution will go
first followed by the defense and then
the prosecution could give a rebuttal
jurors will select a four person when
they retire to deliberate they will be
allowed to deliberate until 7 30 pm each
night the jury will be given a laptop
and all the audio videos and exhibits in
the case they will not be given a
transcript of specific testimony if the
jury has questions the attorneys will
appear via zoom to hear them
jesse this is a little bit peculiar but
makes a lot of sense considering covet
19 restrictions typically a defense and
prosecution will be in close proximity
during deliberations to be able to come
back to the courtroom to discuss any
exhibits or testimony that the jury
wants to hear but of course covert
restrictions are making a little bit
more difficult jesse all right it'll be
interesting to watch thanks brian
remember the derrick chauvin derrick
shoven is facing three charges second
degree murder second degree manslaughter
and third degree murder and he faces up
to 40 years in prison if he's convicted
and as we await a verdict cities across
the country are already preparing for
protests
how
what's going to happen
should a
bad decision come out of the chauvin
trial
without any question
without any hesitation
without any pushback
everybody said we cannot have what
happened
a year ago
we can speak up
but we cannot tear up
if it goes wrong
speak up protest
but do not tear up
now both sides have agreed to the
standard jury instructions but with some
exceptions such as the prosecution's
request for the so-called accomplice
liability suggesting that officer king's
actions also contributed to george
floyd's death
the state requested an aiding and
embedding instruction and instruction on
accomplished liability under crim jig
4.01
we provided notice of this theory of
liability back in february when the
state filed its initial draft jury
instruction the evidence shows that mr
king's actions were also potentially a
substantial causal factor uh the
pressure on his back on mr boyd's back
uh may have resulted in positional
asphyxia causing the striploid's death
and the the testimony of dr tobin dr
smock
provides powerful evidence of that
so we think the evidence readily
supports submitting this accomplished
theory of liability to the jury with
respect to mr shogun
derek chovan's attorney objected to
aiding and abetting coming into the jury
instructions but said that if it does it
should only be read
once and for ease of ease of purposes it
should be ease of in understanding the
instructions i should say if the court
is going to put that back in it should
be in a single place and then it should
be removed
from the definit from the definition so
there was that whole discussion of how
many times where is it going to be
right so yes if the court is going to
put it in it should be in a single place
okay let's break it down brian what's
the strategy here by the prosecution in
arguing accomplice liability
the strategy is to broaden any way of
including culpability for derek shovin
to say that he could be either the
principal or the accomplice in the death
of george floyd and so it could not just
be that his knee on george floyd's neck
and one knee on his back caused his
death but that he could have contributed
to george floyd's death with a
former officer king's
knee on his back as well that's very
damaging information for derek shovin
and former officer king but i know at
least two former officers in the
minneapolis police department who are
going to be ecstatic to hear that
information and that's opera former
officer tu tau and lane
terry the prosecution did mention
allegations against the other police
officers but do you think the jury is
going to be confused by this accomplice
liability charge
you know what jesse they might be a
little confused because they did not
hear specific allegations as related to
king but what they did hear is doctors
tobin and smock talk about the fact that
king did have his knee or weight on top
of george floyd and that could have been
a contributing factor to george floyd's
death so they've heard some testimony
and the charge itself says that he could
be guilty of this crime of aiding and
abetting another person when the
defendant intentionally aided this other
person in the crime that other person
being king so the jury could very well
come back with aiding and abetting okay
there's more to talk about in the derek
chauvin trial but in other news it's
actually been a few months since the
country's most prolific serial killer
died samuel little actually tried to
help identify some of his victims and
here on the long crime network we're
taking an in-depth look at sam little in
a two-part episode of prime crime in
part one we explore the killings how
little escaped justice for so long and
his recorded confessions we also speak
with three people who actually
interviewed a little and what he had to
say was frightening
you know you first see him he's this
little old man in a wheelchair
that will remind me of a little man on
the porch
rocking in a chair telling you his
stories about his life although his
stories were demented there was no
remorse whatsoever it was a matter of
fact i got him to kill
and he went into great detail in his
crimes
and as we listen to these chilling
details we also ask was little telling
the truth about all this to an end to
law and crime still ahead on long crime
daily the investigation into chicago
police
[Music]
and welcome back everybody one of the
experts that testified for derek
shovin's defense faced a grilling from
prosecutors about his opinion of what
killed george floyd anjanette levy's
here to tell us why it's not the first
time dr david fowler's findings have
been questioned and jeanette
yeah that's right jesse dr david fowler
was a medical examiner for many many
years and depending on who you ask you
will get a different opinion about him
i am retired dr fowler spent hours
detailing his opinion that george floyd
died of a cardiac arrhythmia due to his
heart disease and being restrained by
law enforcement his
significant contributory conditions
would be the toxicology the fentanyl and
methamphetamine
there is
exposure to a vehicle exhaust
that drew the ire of prosecutors along
with him labeling the manner of death
undetermined not homicide do you agree
with me that there was no finding of
carbon monoxide poisoning
from mr from dr baker's autopsy review i
do
fowler was the chief medical examiner
for the state of maryland for nearly two
decades he ruled freddie gray's death in
police custody in 2015 a homicide former
baltimore county homicide detective ken
lang worked with fowler i thought he was
phenomenal lang worked with fowler from
2004 to 2007. he is the type of doctor
that likes to teach while uh going
through the investigation and so any
opportunity that he had while we were in
the autopsy room
he would take that opportunity to teach
detectives and and other people about
the different medical
anomalies or things that we were seeing
you're under arrest but fowler faces a
lawsuit in another case that is similar
to george floyd's the death of anton
black in 2018. black's family claims he
really died of positional asphyxia
during a struggle with police fowler
ruled black's death an accident stating
he died a sudden cardiac death and that
bipolar disorder contributed we've come
across not just this case but others
where it involves black men or brown men
mostly black men being killed by the
police and dr fowler in his office
always finding that it was something
else that killed them other than what we
clearly see and know
the maryland attorney general has
actually asked that the anton black
lawsuit be dismissed i reached out to dr
fowler directly to see if he would do an
interview with us and thus far i have
not heard back from him
when he retired back in 2019 both his
colleagues and his staff offered praise
for him jesse all right thanks ange now
brian let's say during deliberations
jurors want to review dr fowler's
testimony how exactly can they do that
so it's going to be interesting they're
going to have a laptop in the jury
deliberation room and so they'll be able
to go back and look at exhibits or video
but they can't look at specific
transcripts of the testimony for that
we're going to see what we usually see
being a note sent to the judge and the
jury asking to see
whoever's testimony whether it be dr
fowler dr tobin chief aerodondo and from
there the lawyers will have a zoom call
with the judge to describe
what part of that testimony will come in
or not based on the questions from the
jurors
now terry the jury is going to be
instructed that expert witness testimony
should be given the same level of
importance as other testimony from other
witnesses not more not less so how do
you think the jury is going to view dr
fowler's testimony
you know jesse part of the jury
instruction is also going to say for an
expert you should look at his education
his training his experience and the jury
might actually consider a couple of
issues like the fact that part of his
training was outside of the united
states the fact that he is not a
pulmonary
cardiologist he's not a toxologist and
he could not even locate the appropriate
research the other thing and angenette
mentioned this is the fact that his
conclusions were far different from dr
tobin's conclusions and he was wrong on
the carbon monoxide so i think the jury
is going to look at this in totality and
they may just very well discount
everything that dr you know
fowler had to say and janet real quick
did the attorney for anton black's
family watched dr fowler's testimony in
the chauvin trial
yeah he did and he said basically that
he has this history of ignoring the
obvious that was ken ravenel's
assessment of that because he believes
that it was the knee on derek shovin's
neck that caused george floyd's death so
he thinks that there's a clear pattern
here a history of him doing these types
of things and it didn't sound like he
was surprised by dr fowler's testimony
in the shoving case wow he's not mincing
any words all right coming up on long
crime daily how a city is reacting to
the fatal shooting of a 13 year old
after a police pursuit plus we speak to
a local attorney about derek chovin's
decision not to take the stand in his
own defense the right call or a mistake
[Music]
both sides have rested in the derrick
chauvin trial but the case isn't done
yet long crimes kim johnson is in
minneapolis and has more on what's next
for the trial of the former officer kim
hi jesse yeah the jurors have the day
off and are enjoying a long weekend
before heading back to court on monday
for closing statements
did derek chauvin miss a major
opportunity to sway the jury by deciding
not to testify that is a question being
debated by legal analysts closely
monitoring this trial it seems like it
was a difficult decision for the defense
his defense attorney eric nelson said
they'd gone back and forth at length
including until the very night before
the judge asked is this your decision
not to testify and chauvin said it is
your honor well-known minnesota criminal
defense attorney joe tamborino tells me
he thinks that was a mistake
but in the end how do you not testify in
a case like this you've got to get up in
front of that jury and say basically two
things number one is you're sorry you
have to humanize yourself i'm sorry i
didn't mean for this to happen mr floyd
didn't deserve this and the second thing
you have to do is fill in the blanks
here's why i had my knee on his neck
here's the kind of pressure i was using
it wasn't great pressure i was using the
knee as an abs i mean i could go on and
on but that's a missed opportunity now
tamborino believes the defense may have
been worried about cross-examination and
putting chauvin on the stand was a risk
not worth taking the defense did call
seven witnesses total to raise doubt
around the cause of death was it
chauvin's knee or was it something else
drugs health problems or even carbon
monoxide poisoning from the squad car it
will soon be up to the jury to decide
that the world is watching many civil
rights advocates say that this trial is
a referendum on a race policing and
holding cops accountable when they kill
on the job jesse
kim what's the feeling on the ground
right now for how people are preparing
for the verdict i mean have you heard
anything about stores or schools maybe
yeah well plywood continues to go up
more and more by the day law enforcement
continues to be an ever more noticeable
present throughout and around the
courthouse and speaking of schools
minneapolis public schools just
announced that they will be going back
to distance
learning for the second half of next
week meaning all school buildings will
be closed all kids will be learning from
home and that is anticipation of a
verdict being reached next week jesse
pretty incredible to think about all
right thanks kim when we come back 13
year old adam toledo shot and killed by
police in chicago last month the newly
released video and reaction from the
city's mayor next
[Music]
newly released police video shows the
fatal shooting of a 13-year-old boy by a
chicago police officer adam toledo was
one of the youngest people killed by
police in illinois we want to warn you
this next story may be difficult to
watch
chicago police say they were responding
to a report of shots fired in the little
village neighborhood in the early
morning of march 29th an officer's body
cam video shows one of the cops running
after 13-year-old adam toledo yelling
for him to stop please stop
stop
stop toledo can be seen turning towards
the officer with his hands in the air
seconds later the officer fires
the officer calls for help then begins
cpr shots fired
more officers arrive on scene and try to
provide medical aid
the officer walks behind the fence and
shines his flashlight on what appears to
be a gun
officials also released video from a
nearby surveillance camera which appears
to show toledo throwing something behind
a fence before turning around the videos
were released by chicago's civilian
police oversight agency after they were
shown to the teen's family an attorney
for the toledo family says videos show
the teen was complying with police
orders and had already dropped the gun
when he was shot on march 29th police
reportedly had spotted two suspects in
an alley 21 year old ruben roman was
arrested
put your hands behind your back
prosecutors said at a bond hearing for
roman that he had fired the gun the
prosecutor also said toledo was holding
it when he was shot and killed the cook
county state attorney's office is now
walking back that statement saying in
part an attorney who works in this
office failed to fully inform himself
before speaking in court roman is facing
charges of felony reckless discharge of
a firearm felony unlawful use of a
weapon by a felon and felony
endangerment of a child
after the videos were released the mayor
of chicago held a presser and said that
they were excruciating for her to watch
but watching
the body cam footage
which shows
young adam
after he's shot
is extremely difficult
and i would just say
and i've said this too
a number of people on my my staff our
cabinet
as a mom
this is not something you want children
to see
look i i i don't want to get into the
real substance of this because the
independent investigation is going on
but i've seen no evidence whatsoever
that adam toledo shot at the police
brian what a story uh what is your
initial reaction to this and how do you
think that investigation is going to
play out
see the problem jesse is uh
in my brain i have to fight between what
i am
am i the older brother of someone 12
years younger than i am and i remember
when my brother was 13 and i was 25 the
knucklehead things that he got into
but i'm also a lawyer
and so it's the struggle of
remembering what a 13 year old is and
understanding that situation of them
being around a 21 year old person they
probably shouldn't be around
and running for their life and in the
midst of complying in 0.8 seconds gets
shot and killed
but i know what the narrative is going
to be i know what
the police department is going to throw
at this boy
that he should be
more responsible and more aware of his
surroundings than a police officer who
is trained to deal with these situations
i don't have any hope that there will be
any change of how this occurred i know
this happened in chicago 30 years ago
and i'm fearful that it could happen 30
years from now so it just worries me on
many levels
terry you know this isn't the first time
that chicago police officers have faced
criticism over the way that they've
responded to calls
what more can be done to address the
issue of excessive use of force
jesse these cases need to be
investigated at the highest levels
because there are so many of these cases
across the country
and especially when it's talking about a
child like we had with tamir rice in
cleveland ohio and in that case
fortunately the attorneys for the family
have asked for the case to be reopened
they wrote a letter to the department of
justice so perhaps we will be seeing
investigations and perhaps we will be
seeing some prosecutions of these cases
so that there can be justice for the
families involved
just awful to think about when you think
about the age of these victims and
what's at stake and all this happening
right now in the middle of the